welcome to the Apologetics Road
show we are at JFK International Airport
New York City about to head to Paris
France the city of
estrogen I've been up for 20 I've been
up for over 24 hours so I think I'm
about to sleep pretty hard on the plane
we were both asked to speak at the North
American pmics Conference you know pmics
against Islam and stuff but because of
security concerns we haven't really been
able to tell anybody what we're doing
where it is anything like that that lead
that leads to kind of a weird situation
like we have no idea who's going to be
there if we can't tell people hey
everyone go to the conference like who's
going to be watching the presentation we
actually have no idea who's going to be
there we won't find out until we uh
until we get there I know I'll be there
for
years so basically we have no idea who's
going to be there but we'll find out a
couple days from now yes so since we
were uh heading to London I thought we
should make a little detour to Paris
because the Unstoppable fire hose of
awesome ideas that is my brain came up
with an idea a long time ago for a video
that has to do with the Venus de Milo in
the L so we're going to we're going to
head by there and uh get a little video
and after that we're going to jump on
the Eurostar train underneath the water
right that's how it goes and I think I'm
not sure right well I mean it's got to
right you can't can't be going over the
Chunnel so jump on the Eurostar and then
we're in London and then we are going to
hit Speaker's Corner and I know our dawa
friends are going to love it I have got
a special
shirt just for the occasion so basically
when we go to Speaker's Corner with
David's special
shirt I'm also going to be up on the
ladder and and we're hoping some of the
dawa guys are there I think they're
going to love it oh they're going to
love it all
right in New York got to get the
sun Yankee
shirt so at the conference I'll be
speaking about uh what the crown says
about the Bible PR stes of jihad and I'm
going to talk about all the Cults okay
some of the Cults that have spun out of
Islam you can't talk about all of them
it's like a traon just the urban
Cults we'll see what happens what else
are you going to talk
about every time the Quran mentions the
gospel you're going through
it oh that sounds good I'm going to do
one on the Gnostic influence inside the
Quran how it's got narcissism in there
we'll have some clips for y'all it'll be
dope I'm also going to do one about how
Hebrew israelism is a new competitor to
Islam and analyze some of their
theological clashes it is they've got
some competition that's right
[Music]
us while you're in Paris watching
Thriller oh um
it's related to a video you'll see it
though it's actually I'm using a clip
for this in a video going to have to be
a short clip
though all right so we're walking back
after recording
vocab making a
video tell them what that was about how
to let people know Hebrew Israelites are
here in Paris France raising awareness
letting them know spreading all over
yeah that was a that was a really I I
had no idea but yeah yeah uh we went to
the location where uh the Hebrew
Israelites here in
Paris are active but anyway here's a
clip if you live in a city in the United
States you probably seen a group of
Hebrew Israelites holding c as they call
it you probably also know that this
usually means that they're yelling
loudly into a microphone and pointing
people to a Sandwich Board sign on the
ground all right and now we are heading
back to the hotel work on some scripts
to get ready for the morning scripts
scripts scripts more
[Music]
scripts here we have an actual sculpture
representing Muhammad's teaching about
breastfeeding adults
well that sucks uh been playing that
video for years actually had the point
in mind almost 20 years ago used the
point in my doctor liation I've used it
in debates and stuff finally made a
video awesome video about it wanted to
get it just right we went in there
recorded recorded the entire thing uh on
new uh new unit here that I had not
tried thoroughly uh went ahead and we
recorded the recorded it went out and I
found out that once it is on its maximum
uh resolution super ultra 4K whatever it
only records in 5 minute increment so I
only got the first 5 minutes and we made
sure we got in there really early at the
first so it wasn't crowded and then step
back in for a possible re
re-recording and it was jam-packed and
so but here's a
clip this is the Venus De Milo it was
discovered in an underground Cavern on
the island of Milos a little over 2
centuries ago most people think that
it's a sculpture and that it was
therefore made by a sculptor but I'd
like to challenge this silly
Superstition I say there's no way the
Venus de Milo had a sculptor think about
it what sort of sculptor would make a
statue of Venus with no
arms you know as well as I that any
sculptor worthy of the name would have
put some arms on this thing since we
know that a sculptor would have made a
statue of Venus with arms and yet we
find none it should be obvious to
everyone that the armless of this
whatever it is makes belief in a
sculptor completely
irrational and so did I want to
re-record the entire thing in a crap
situation these are just kind of a
decision you got to make as YouTuber
sometimes like okay I'm in a situation
this wouldn't be exactly what I want do
I go ahead and record it anyway um or do
I wait until it's exactly what I want
and different situations you make
different choices this was particularly
a video where I was like I would
actually rather fly back to Paris on a
different day cuz we have to leave
because we're heading to uh uh heading
to London but this is actually a video
that I think is important enough that I
would rather actually come back to Paris
and record it to get it exactly the way
I want but got to be their first thing
or it gets really really full on the
plus side we did get some stuff uh with
vocab going through the Antiquities
select uh section and checking out some
near Eastern artifacts that confirm the
Bible and so here's a clip of that this
is the Misha St sometimes called the
moabit stone and in here it's more proof
of the Bible's accuracy because it
accurately mentions one of moabites gods
Kos numbers
21:29 woe to you oh Moab you perish o
people of Kos he has given his sons as
fugitives and his daughters into
captivity to an Amorite King Sion so
this is more proof because it gets other
nations Gods correct here here's the
thing vocab vocab here's the thing you
don't want to be trying new things when
you've on location you've never tried
this before you don't want to do it
right there new equipment new ideas
here's the thing vo you got to test it
out beforehand okay otherwise you're
going to end up with a screwed up video
why would you do that you're on location
that's not the time to test it out try
for the first time that's single okay
trust me I know that is that is correct
and did all the testing just just never
crossed my mind that there's a video
camera that shuts off after 5 minutes
that shuts off after 5
minutes that's a scenario where you
might want to read all the instructions
on whatever your device is but yeah here
here's the thing that's life hey more of
the train B trains check this out so
we're about to we're about to leave
Paris on the uh Eurostar so we're here
in the uh in the station there's like
like trillions of uh people and uh
businesses here and vocabs all excited
cuz there's a train here get the train
in the
shot right there now how much better
does that look come on look you keep on
he's extra excited because of a train
I'm like dude uh you know lived in the
Bronx for what 13 14 years and I was on
a train like five six days a week and
how many of those trains went underwater
uh the one I was the ones I was on I
think but they went underground
definitely so in your face
look at that look at that it's beautiful
this place is cool I was so happy to see
the Union Jack and David's like oh maybe
someone up here speaks English I'm like
yeah of course it's the English floor
someone up there is going to speak
English and the guy spoke English what
do you expect and it's cool so we're
here massively early uh not sure what
we're going to do probably want to grab
some coffee but uh in case anyone else
is in case anyone else is uh what's this
place called again you remember hold on
I'll tell you go ahe
talk well you're supposed to they gave
us the name so I searched for it cuz I
wanted to know how far it would be from
the hotel to make sure we were here on
time
Gard yeah but I want I don't know I
don't know any french so I was worried
that that just means train station it
might not necessarily be the right place
but yeah there's only one of them anyway
if you're in Paris and you want to go to
London this is where you go let's go uh
let's see what's here real quick G nor
[Music]
he
well we just finished the
Eurostar ride uh we're basically working
on our presentations the entire time
vocab what you think about the Eurostar
great felt like being in the past going
through the countryside eating the food
in the train car but it also felt like
being in the future cuz you got the
Wi-Fi and you're underground it was
great uh definitely one of the coolest
ways to travel I have to say so if
you're going to from uh Paris to London
do not get on a plane this is way better
than a it's way better than the plane
way cooler so
100% much better you heard it here folks
Eurostar rocks all right now we got to
find a uh train through London to get to
our
hotel
and talk to you soon
[Music]
Judaism the early movement was an
expression of cultural black nationalism
and found it expression as a result
of American the Bel andic of the black
Jew upon which so part of what we want
to do here today is take away the shock
Factor now there's other beliefs we can
talk about what I'm going to do is come
back to this slide if we have time to
discuss other beliefs I have a little
chart with icons it's a lot of fun
actually I thought I told you to get
better conversation
Partners but I will answer this anyways
we know who John is John was the son of
Zebedee he had a brother named James who
was a fisherman he was From Galilee we
know who John is all of our gospel
manuscripts from the earliest times say
according to John so there they're not
Anonymous we know who he is we know his
family we know his father we know his
brother hi I'm here with Ananda also
known as
nectarios hello how you doing uh I heard
I heard I heard someone say that you're
actually an ex-muslim yeah so I'd like
to uh I'd like to have you on for a live
stream to go through this but why don't
you give everyone the uh the quick
version quick version is um I joined
Islam I was inside I saw the arguments
against Christianity and honestly just
in a simple sense the fact that they
were so bad showed me that Christianity
actually was very intelligent and it
showed me that yo this intellectual
tradition is terrible it's trash it's
dooo water so when I was like deep in it
I was like to the mandm yo we have no
args every ARG gets defeated we're dead
we're trash so like when I was there and
I was saying to them like yo like I read
these passages from 48 to 53 what's
response and I was like guys we're
getting farted just because we lied to
ignorant because this is what used to
annoy me as I saw the da tricks they
were debate arguments they lost with
people they knew couldn't answer and I
see this in the corner too they just
take the same ARS recycled and I just
thought yo if this is what we're doing
how are we upon the truth if we have to
be so dishonest so deceptive so IR
receptive to information so I was just
like yo I don't want to be in this
Shorty car they sold me no more I want
to get a new car Jesus Christ the best
car you know what I'm
saying all right well that's awesome
well
uh how can people uh follow you follow
your work cuz you're at Speaker's Corner
you're one of the guys that's holding it
that's holding it down there now yeah
I'm at Speaker's Corner I'm on Ananda
apologetics that's a n a I'm going to
forget to spell my own name Ananda it's
exactly like it sounds right NBA I
always forget I'm terrible about
spelling but yeah anander apologetics
sub to me on YouTube I do have a Tik Tok
I'm a bit inactive there but I might get
more active um also shout out the mandom
shout out Sig shout all those people who
very instrumental in helping me come to
the faith and gu me so yeah man all
right I'll uh I'll have the links uh to
all those in the description box glory
to
God how can he how can he carry a stupid
Bible that have Pagan pick Jesus you
should be ashamed of yourself you for
admitting who you are the devil nobody
would say the Bible stes unless they're
of the devil I'm telling you now this is
stupid this is stupid from Satan he's
stupid he stupid I'm telling you now Cal
down calm down no have it on record have
it on record I said that Jesus is stupid
Jesus is son of the devil yeah this
Bible came from Satan
yeah million people who is this 25
million people is they don't even know
their history even do you know even
Putin crowd of people talking to his
Echo color the color of is see the point
I like this brother you have an audience
and you're talking to you need security
brother is he helping you out by shaking
his head every now and then is this what
is this what you came out to do why
don't you guys just stay in McDonald's
and have the conversation this is how
religious debat start don't believe just
talk to him in McDonald's you and just
hanging out not only thater is
translated by a white man do you know
what still Manning an argument is yes
steel Manning an opponent is presenting
his case in the strongest form that you
can
so can you steal man the most powerful
da argument Steel Man the most powerful
daa argument yes I
[Music]
can yo when we come to power yeah we're
going to be chopping the heads off all
the apostates and all the blasphemers
yeah and I going to be sitting there
eating the popcorn while I'm watching
but I can't eat the popcorn now so I
just be eating grapes Fantom Me by smes
to Jenner like
I you know when when SM be graping me in
my mouth you may be wondering why don't
be having my wife graping me in the
mouth but that's because she's too busy
yeah learning her
ABCs and we're proud of
her
[Music]
cop hi everyone I'm in the UK and at a
pmics conference dealing with Islam and
I met my friend John here who's an
ex-muslim but I have to ask how can you
be how could you have been a Muslim your
name is John well I am now follower of
the Lord Jesus Christ and when I became
Christian I um I read the Gospel of John
and I I was in love with how uh the John
the the Gospel of John said in the
beginning was the word and the Word was
God and the word became flesh and I
choose to become John new God New Faith
new life with the Lord Jesus Christ hey
so you're from Yemen why don't you go
ahead and why don't you just go ahead
and uh tell us how you uh ended up
leaving Islam and uh becoming a
Christian so I grew up in Yemen into a
Muslim family uh into a devoted to
Muslim family and my family taught me
how to pray how to fast how to read
Quran and 2014 I want to I was doubtful
about Islam because I felt there is no
spiritual connection between me and God
the Creator and this is we I ended up to
go to Mecca I was the luckiest one to go
to Mecca the house of Allah and in Mecca
I was going around the block the house
of Allah and I I realiz this is human
being made this is not from God and
there in front of Kaa I rejected Islam I
give up Islam in front of Kaaba and that
was very hard wait just to be clear you
became an apostate from Islam in front
of the Caba in front of Caba in in the
front of the most holy place of Islam
the capital of Islam wow so uh so uh
what what happened after that after that
I was agnostic for three years it was
the most hardest life in my the most
hardest three years in my life because
in Islam as you said if you are apostate
if you denied Islam if you rejected
Islam there is a Hadith whoever change
his religion should be killed so I have
to be secret for three years it was very
hard then I um I left Yan and I met
Christians and they T me about Jesus
Christ and I start to read the the
gospel of Matthew and the the teaching
of Jesus Christ the ceremony in the
mount and that changed my life upside
down I said this is the god I'm looking
for this is the god who died for me and
rose again he's alive he loved me so
much that he died on the cross and rose
again so I give my life to Jesus Christ
I become new a new creation new believer
and this is why I chose that I become
John and now God called me to sh to
share my faith with with the whole
Nations and with my people with yemenis
because I always declare Yemen for
Christ oh they really need it down there
of course they need the Lord J really
need it down there yeah they need the
Lord Jesus Christ everybody need the
everyone everyone need need the Lord
Jesus Christ absolutely so how can
people uh follow your work so my name is
John ranim on Instagram they call me Tik
toer John um uh on Tik Tok Facebook
YouTube John ranim and I will put the
links to all those in the description
box thanks brother thank you so much
it's an honor to meet you and you are
one of the um cfer one of the most uh
infidels in the world against Islam the
cfer
king God bless you thank you hey yo it's
okay hey all right we we are heading to
uh High Park Speakers Corner right now
we didn't get to record a bunch of uh
much behind the scenes stuff yesterday
because we were doing lots of speaking
and then we broke up we did record lots
of stuff I was recording some uh quick
quick interviews with ex-muslims and
vocab managed to find bunch of different
uh Hebrew Israelite groups and so on so
two different two different ones and
some newans yeah so anyway we'll be
sharing footage of some of that stuff
but uh
think it's about to get fun
especially
especially since Muslims have announced
that they'll brutally murder me if I
show up here and I invented my own new
form of body armor and I'm here to see
it let's see what
happens speaker caller right across the
street all right now say the thing the
ti Tock time to rock yes no I mind at
all you okay okay
cool
you you're good he Budd we're like we're
like 15t deep into speaker corner and
that's like five selfies that's cool
that's cool we get recognized way way
way more here than we do in the US's
up perfect thank you so much
he has to
come my there you go guys my hero I hope
you're all going to listen to David wood
and I hope you'll all watch his back as
well no
way hello hello
hello comment on one your video
yesterday and I put D David will ever
come to London cuz it's not safe for him
and here you are mate oh you haven't
seen you haven't seen un safe yet watch
wait for
it go get
you hey how you doing how you doing I
almost became a Muslim and I searched up
the and one of your videos came up just
like
[Applause]
that so I invented my own form of body
yeah that's right new form of body armor
[Applause]
Jesus what's that what's
that tell us what it is stab me without
stabbing your
butt I'm now the safest man in the world
why why why
David which K is that David which Kat is
that which karat is that David knows
knows
where they be hiding
bro they going to know now I couldn't be
here today yeah I teaching my wife for
abcs on the white Bo got her and I got
smiles to
J M he's probably busy delivering his
invisible Mon and plus I got the busy
day selling zga on the
website I been proud of that I'm going
use my two minutes to restate the
question asking is asking a question the
same as making a
claim speaker cor is
different and then the third one was
what was the language that the was
written let's see if in these 2 minutes
he answers one at least one at least one
at least
one know I should said I
have me you don't control
me thank you not have never never will
be hey hey hey heyy
so so this is just really you ask
questions you refuse to answer then you
go on completely different topic so this
is just say whatever we want right this
just what we say what this is just say
whatever this is say whatever we want
right I wouldn't answer a single
question from anyone and anyone have
discuss you don't needan to give me
time was a child
molester he was a rap
[Applause]
[Music]
Christ Christ
Christ chrus Christ
chrr chrus Christus Christus Christ is
CHR is Lord Jesus Christ is lordus
Christ isus Christ isus Christ isus
Christ is Lord
[Applause]
he wasn't
ready so what made you decide to come to
speak his Corner today with Jay Smith
Danny Tomo and all of them heavy guns I
don't see no Muslims they run away they
run away yeah that's a real that's a
real question we thought hey we're here
for a conference since we're here for a
conference we might as well go to
Speaker's Corner have some debates come
on and we can't find one
[Music]
is Muhammad
hij
Al I'll tell you where Ali da is he's at
home getting graped in the mouth by
smiles to
J I heard did y'all hear Ali dawa say
that one single Muslim could just take
on all the
Christians where where is this magical
[Applause]
where look you made such a brilliant
point I don't know if you realize it you
made a brilliant point you said that the
Bible gets this right but you said how
do I know because whatever aligns with
the Quran I see is truth in the Bible
however the Quran doesn't tell you this
about Jesus it doesn't tell you he have
brothers doesn't tell you nothing about
James right so my question is then this
if your method of judging what is true
in the Bible is by using the Quran as a
judge the part of the Quan doesn't speak
how do you know that it's
true buk
why you one of the biggest biggest
against Islam why sh where's
theace you de this man once in a
lifetime opportunity will you debate him
VI is waiting for
running have to
speak people watch it
go in
peace don't
knowah 16 verse
125 people tolam and we're
here here the Quran says it
he doesn't want to
talk
have all right we tried ladies and
gentlemen no this protects you from
Poison mam
forgot yeah seven that's okay I hav had
any points thank you
no
[Applause]
de
Dr you're a salty bro you're beened yeah
that's bad but banging a 9-year-old girl
is good
age of conting Christianity H what's the
age
of years these people these people sleep
with 5 years old this
Christian won't let an
answer simp answer simple answer in
Christianity do unto others as you would
have them do unto you amen amen if you
were a n9y old girl would you want some
creepy 54y old
Heaven
d as
as slave Mohamed had all kinds of black
slaves and his followers no no his
followers started the African slave
trade a thousand years before the US
existed has wom as slaves proud of
that that we'll be
watching watching
do you believe in some of the book and
you reject the
other do you hear that do you hear the
party just quoted
justed quoted Surah 2 verse 85 of the
Quran where Allah is criticizing Jews
for not following the Torah and he says
do you follow part of the book and not
all of it talking about the Torah and he
says he will send them to hell if they
do not follow all of the Torah it's
right here in the Quran Surah 2 ver 85
so according to Allah Jews have to
believe all the Torah not just Parts
what will every Muslim di here at
speaker Corner tell you about the Torah
just believe Parts just believe Parts
they say they say the opposite of what
their God says and
theya let me
one if the trajectory continues as it
tast if the trajectory continues as it
is he'll keep interrupting us he
destroyed bro here
destroy Mohamed guy who destroyed the
myth of perfect
preservation thank you hey I love more
than you I love that
guy the and the
narrative David David when you upload
this you have blow my face okay what
blow my face okay bling out
BL being a coward don't show up if
you're
aard this is another ver this has been
abated this has
been you go to the next verse uh they
would they extinguish the light of Allah
with mouth criticism is what they're
preaching what they're
saying there's nothing here about
attack there's no point there's no point
no from the beginning
of talking
about and it doesn't
exist I don't think it's right only
mention one
time it can be misrepresented app but
guys can I tell you up till now I see
that you are saying things based on your
expertise and knowledge I'm I don't mean
anything the
count
all that's true here here's the thing
though again we read the entire passage
you I finish I know but you can take
this out true true true true why that's
why I read it context right 928 933
here's the thing here here let me just
say this let me just say that so I read
928 to 9 talking about fighting every
reason that is for fighting people has
to be with do with Christian Jewish
beliefs or practices there's not one
word about about fighting P just let me
finish there's not one word about oh and
because they're attacking you it's look
they say this look they do this look
they're worshiping this look they're
worshiping that one second one second
one
second and so here's my here's my main
issue if you say it means something else
that it's actually just talking about
self-defense and only applies in a
certain no no what the point is what
okay if it means something else and 14
centuries of Muslims completely
misinterpreted it I'm not saying that
yeah you are I mean read Read's
commentary on read M's battles with the
Propet in the same Quran he says
that you will find
when in says says when the pagans and
the Jews or some Christians and some
Jews form an alliance right they will be
hostile at that time you will find it
doesn't say Christians it say those who
profess their Christian identity and say
we are Christians the PRI of the they
will show you love and affection because
number one they' got priesthood number
two they have monkhood and they're not
Arab so the Quran is not contradictory
it's obviously not talking about all
Jews and Christians you can just get
vers of the misrepresent you you got to
look at the whole entirety of the Quran
you that's not that's not the method
according Quran itself no you're doing
your own method no you guys are saying
oh this verse sounds like this but
there's this other verse in this other
passage that sounds like that no I'm not
I'm the Quran the Quran the method that
the Quran gives Surah 2 vers 106 Allah
abrogates or cancels earlier Revelations
and so if you see this it do Abate or
cancel to okay just to make
it LA and legislation from that because
there is
no there no let me put it this way if
Allah's speech is clear you agree that
the Quran CLA you don't think it's who
he these are the vers of the
clear we have to examine and do lots of
work I'm going to say I'm just going to
say this if Allah is talking about
fighting and subjugating people he needs
to be pretty darn clear about what he's
talking about and according to you he's
so unclear that 14 centuries of Muslim
Scholars concluded this about offensive
J and it's not until and it's not until
we get to you guys we finally figured
out the
mystery and you're saying there's a
treaty I'm saying okay what what treaty
the
treat that's that's talking about the
pagans it's talking about Jews and
Christians it's a different passage I go
to the entire passage I go to the
commentaries com and you could go to 14
centuries of Muslim scholarship up down
down to the 21st century and then you
guys and by the way I could I I I wish
you were right I just don't believe
that's what the what and if it is if put
it this way if you guys are right
I have to say Allah is the worst
Communicator in history if he means only
fight in self-defense and it comes out
fight those who do not believe and then
people get killed over and over again
over where does he say is about a treaty
that's what I mean if he's saying fight
people break a treaty but he doesn't
mention the treaty you're massively more
clear than Allah you're massively
clearer than Allah I like you way better
than Allah everyone we need to take up a
collection so he can write the Quran and
me make it mean what Allah said make it
me make Allah mean what he says
right is that name in
the is it anywhere in the
Traditions so read what happens to that
Prophet which I have not commanded him
to speak or which he speaks in the name
of other
gods the prophet shall die he must be
put to
death so you're saying the mhammad has
to be put to death because he comes in
the name of another God and we know that
Allah is not that God no we know Yahweh
has to be that God so Deuteronomy 88
shuts down Muhammad right there
absolutely but then you get to 543 where
the historical background is some Jews
come to Muhammad to settle the dispute
and Allah says why do they come to you
for judgment when they have the Torah
and in the historical background of the
Hadith Muhammad is on this judgment
cushion and he gets off the cushion he
says bring me the and puts the Torah on
the Judgment cushion he says I believe
in you and in the one who revealed you
and then so it goes on 543 down to 547
then it says uh let the people of the
Gospel judge by what Allah have to
reveal theirin and then it goes to 568
it says um people of the book we have no
ground to stand upon unless we stand
upon the Torah and the gospel and all
the Revelation that has come to us so we
read all this and then we talk to a
Muslim and they say your scriptures been
corrupted you can't trust you all have
to judge by the Quran it's like it
sounds like the opposite of what Allah
is saying to us you have to judge by by
what God the the mean the word of Jesus
in fact thean the word of Jesus I it
also says we have it yeah I think the
red those CHR that don't
judge true that's true it says we're no
better than those who Rebel if we don't
judge by the go that's what I'm saying
so yeah the point I'm making here is we
could go to any one of the like Sunni
dawa guys and they would tell us our
books been corrupted it's it's we need
to get rid of like Ali da said you have
one 12 of poison you have One Drop of
Poison and the drink and you drink it
then the whole thing it's going to
poison you right so so the point the
point is it what what the da guys s what
the dawa guys say it just doesn't sound
like what the Quran is saying and so we
say and we point it out and it's like I
don't even know what to do at some point
when when they will say the exact
opposite in other words if you read if
in other words if you read sah 5 ver 43
and Allah says why do they come to you
for judgment when they have the Torah
and then 5 and then 547 let the people
of the go if you were just to read that
and say okay I'm a Christian what am I
supposed to judge by you say the gospel
but if I ask a DA guy what am I supposed
to judge by say the Quran not the gospel
and I say that's that's not what Allah
says in the Quran so why are you saying
it but look at what he said he said he
says bring me the Torah they bring the
Torah on the Judgment cushion he says I
believe in you and in the one who
revealed you that's a strange thing to
say if you're just saying I believe in
Parts but the rest have been corrupted
like I believe in parts of the Quran I
would never say I believe in you and in
the one who revealed you I would say
yeah I believe in parts of it but it
would be very I would never in a million
years say I believe in you and the one
who revealed you I agree that's what the
say we're not disagreeing here we're not
disagree we're on the same Pace we agree
that the dawa guys are wrong
yeah we're in the
airport
gwick London
England London England
rocks that's
right so uh after Speaker's Corner
which was crazy and fun you've heard
that it's addictive right I've heard
that would totally be
addictive that is uh that is awesome
going there and uh when everyone would
surround me I would suddenly feel like
the
cabba they start kissing on you they try
to everyone was trying to kiss me they
were all trying to kiss me like I'm the
black stone
anyway while I'm there guy comes up to
we all supposed to go hang out
afterwards all the everyone from the
conference
but uh while I'm there a guy comes up to
me he's like hey uh over at a college we
have a group of like missionaries
meeting from around the world who are
focused on uh evangelizing Muslims do
you want to come and I'm thinking no I'm
I've got other I've got other stuff to
do and but he he keeps asking me and
asking me and asking me and then I'm
thinking okay well maybe God wants me to
I said but you'd have to verify that
with uh I said go check with Jay because
you know kind of the the leader out
there and then he comes back he says
yeah Jay says it's fine so anyway went
over there it was what was it an hour an
hour drive and we were in the Woods by
that time yeah it looked a lot different
than London yeah you were worried about
hitting a deer like we're going to hit a
deer out here that's exactly what I said
so anyway it was a super long drive then
we get to this uh Christian uh Christian
college but there there were there were
people from all how many people think
all over the world I talked to an
Australian I talked to folks from
Southeast Asia there was Americans there
I talk to a guy from Virginia there's
people from everywhere and of course
Tanzania I think Burundi yeah everywhere
and they all are missionaries who
specialize in Muslim contexts and that's
the whole point of this Missionary
Training thing they were doing yeah so
they were already there for a uh it's a
I don't know if it was several days or
weeks or whatever but it's a intensive
training and stuff so uh they brought us
over there and uh VAB spoke for a couple
minutes and then uh
was totally unplanned he goes I'm right
about to go up he goes yeah go ahead and
speak for about an hour wait what he
goes Inspire them Inspire them and I and
I had my suit jacket and a nice collar
shirt and David had sweatpants and a
t-shirt straight from Speakers Corner
guy guy literally nicked me from
Speaker's
Corner um but it's cool they all knew
who I was like the like what uh when
when I was getting up they the guy goes
everyone here know nail kesi and they
all said yeah and they go and how' nail
become Christian and then uh yeah so
anyway they knew aost Prophet they knew
everyone like in the circle was wild
yeah so anyway that was real cool um so
we finished that then we got back all
late what' we get like 2 hours sleep 2
and a half 2 and 1/2 hours sleep last
night and then had to jump up and head
to the airport and then have an English
breakfast we did have a banging
breakfast here at the
airport all right I had salmon and eggs
you yeah cuz you had some yogurt or
granola or something
anyway all right what do you think of
the trip
man I I would come here multiple times a
year if I was able to but I'm hoping at
least once a year yeah we definitely got
to come at least once a year go down
there and Rule Speaker's
Corner Christians were crushing it down
there man Christians were crushing it
and I I just have to say it's
uh it's really encouraging uh to see so
many young guys because in the US it's
it's usually older guys and then we we
get we're excited about God loic he's
like a young a young guy who's really
active and so on uh but man there are
like there are like 20 God Logics I met
over here so they're really active and
uh they're really smart they're learning
and they are I mean they are just they
are just wrecking the dawa over here and
it's awesome
good trip good to meet all these people
I'm going to sleep on this plane I'm
going to sleep on this plane too and I'm
sure we will
be sharing some fun footage on uh
YouTube and in some live streams so
catch you
soon proba a show proba good mate Che we
go in
it care straight way
[Music]